Thank you for being here.
I'm thrilled to be here, merry Christmas.
And you know what?
Merry Christmas, as you know we're...
Well, we're celebrating Christmas now
because frankly we're
just not sure mankind
is gonna make it to December 25th.
Yeah, let's do it now.
We don't want to miss our last Christmas.
And then we will know that
this is our last Christmas
to which we can make
that much more special.
So nice of you to dress up in the spirit.
Doesn't it... Aren't you
feeling Christmasy right now?
I am. I love Christmas and I still...
I don't think it's ever too
early to start the music.
It is a little too early with
the decorations, I think.
I'd get stick of them by Christmas Eve,
but I just love it.
I love it, love it, love it.
Yeah. Well, we did this again.
We're doing it now.
Because we're not, we think
things are just gonna come
to an end in about four weeks.
Oh God. Oh Lord.
Good thing we can laugh about it, Conan.
Can we though, can we?
I don't know maybe we can, we'll find out.
I can laugh at anything
now I'm that medicated.
You know there's... I have
a little bit of a bone
to pick with you Jane Lynch.
Oh okay sure.
And you're universally beloved.
People love you.
And I'm such a huge fan of your work,
but I do have a complaint,
which is, you've been on my
show many, many, many times,
and every time you're on my show,
you come out, you sit down
and then you immediately
start talking to Andy.
And you do that because you and Andy
have a prior relationship.
You worked on a stage show
years ago before I knew Andy.
You always sit down and
you start talking to Andy,
and then you keep talking to Andy.
This is an actual... This
is the typical interview
that I do with you where...
Look at.. Not even making
eye contact with me.
Not even looking at me,
only looking at Andy
and I find it very insulting.
Well, I'm sorry about that,
I wouldn't have thought that was true
until I saw that photographic evidence.
But I'm sure we included you
in the conversations, I'm sure.
I don't know. I think
you just easily left out.
Is Andy there tonight?
Well, yeah, Andy's
sitting in the audience.
Hey Andy, can you hear me?
Hi Jane?
Hey, how you doing?
I'm doing fine.
How's your dog.
You've had her for a year now, right?
Daisy. Yeah, a little over a year.
A little dollop a Daisy.
I love that dog. She's so cute.
I love that you keep
taking pictures of her
and posting it on Twitter, it's great.
Yeah. Well she's very photogenic.
She's a very pretty dog
and she just keeps
getting bigger and bigger.
It's you know...
Would you say you're a dog person now?
I didn't know why I was getting
a pony when I got a puppy.
Yeah. Would you say that
you're a dog person now?
Oh, absolutely.
I always was.
I have--
Shh.
He was talking about being
a dog person. Go ahead what?
Yeah, no, yeah,
I do, I've always been a dog person.
You have--
I mean everything.
I love animals--
I do too.
I would have cats if my kids
weren't allergic, you know?
Mm-hmm, yeah.
I usually have cats, but
they both passed away
in the last couple of years,
but I do have two dogs.
We usually have three. Believe it or not.
We have two Cocker Spaniels now.
And one of them is kind of an asshole
and the other one is just
really old and blind and deaf.
But we love them both equally.
Yeah.
Andy, ask Conan if he's an animal person,
just so we can include him on this.
Oh shit you're right.
Hey Conan, you've got a dog, right?
Yes. I have two dogs.
Tell us about them.
Loki and Bosco. They're great dogs.
But what kind of dogs are they Conan?
They are Golden Retrievers.
Okay. Hey, your dog is a mix?
Isn't she... Isn't Daisy a mix.
Isn't she like a mutt--
Yeah, she's a mix.
'Cause she's not a pure breed.
I hating people get
pure breeds that just...
My Cockers are men--
I'm sorry.
I'm cutting it off.
Jane, I think that you and I should talk
when there isn't someone interrupting us.
Okay, I think that's probably
a good idea, whatever.
I'll get with you after the show.
Sounds great.
It's great to hear your voice.
I'm sorry I can't see your face.
That's all right.